a sharp fall we were told to expect by
Jeremy Hunt the chancellor only a few
weeks ago
today's inflation numbers show anything
but they remain stubbornly in double
digits close to that 40-year high
unfortunately that's the headline rate
of inflation but behind the headline the
story gets even worse because if we look
into the components of inflation that
individual costs that affect a typical
family some of the things that we have
to buy have written in price a lot more
than 10 percent
energy of course we know has rocketed in
costs over the last 12 months as a
result of the war but so too food and
drink at more than 19 the cost of a
typical weekly shop has dramatically
increased let's put that increase in
food costs into context
it is literally higher than it's ever
been in my lifetime the result of this
is not only that an average weekly shop
is significantly more expensive for a
family in the UK now but also that the
kinds of things that families who have
to buy when they're shopping on a budget
are often the ones that have increased
in price the most some examples Garden
peas more than twice as expensive as
they were in a supermarket this time
last year's Peppers again almost twice
the price even really routine things
like cream crackers and oil fruit juice
these aren't luxury purchases these are
the Staples that we use to fill our
fridges and our ladders and the result
of these kinds of price increases mean
that many families are really starting
to Struggle No no wonder then that so
many are having to have recourse to food
banks and other forms of support
likewise support required for energy and
remember the good old days when a
typical household paid about a thousand
pounds a year for their energies well
those good old days are long gone the
costs for typical household to heat
their homes of course have risen by more
than twofold now about 2 500 pounds a
year for an average UK household capped
by the government's energy price
guarantee if there's light at the end of
the tunnel it is that over the course of
2023 we are expecting to see Energy
prices begin to come off that high
forecasters are now suggesting that by
the end of the year an average household
energy bills would have come down to
closer to two thousand pounds so good
news couldn't come a moment too soon but
still more than twice what that same
household was paying for energy uh 24
months ago
so much for the big picture the
challenge of course is particularly
acute for households on Lower incomes
and the just about managing
here's an example of a household with
two adults and three kids on a modest
household income about 35
000 pounds their rents increased
dramatically over the last 12 months but
look at those cumulative effects of the
cost of grocery increases and the cost
of energy increase for this family as a
case study their total bills have
increased by more than 3 300 pounds
that's almost 10 percent of their entire
income now absorbed and it's for many
families money they just don't have